hello mama they let me say that because
I was good and fast I'm now about to
yield this podium to a gentleman who was
obsessive in Jaws determined and the
Taking of Pelham one two three
biting in the sting and regal in a man
for all seasons and you will soon see
him in black Sunday on the stage among
others Luther tiger at the gates and the
caretaker
he is also written five novels and three
plays ladies and gentlemen the
multi-talented Robert Shaw
Thank You mr. Mehta members of the
Academy and ladies and gentlemen I don't
know which is really superior compliment
I have first to read a telegram from the
eldest of my nine children that's Debra
Ann Shore she's 23 now it reads darling
dad as you are one of the last outposts
of the British Empire please behave
yourself with dignity and so to use the
immortal words of Gilbert and Sullivan
and pretty good words really with a
sense of emotion and a tranquil state of
mind I present the first of my
presenters I recently saw a lovely film
the other side of the mountain and so
you probably know who I'm talking about
the two film stars who talented young
people in the company of those players
miss Marilyn hasit mr. Beau Bridges
for feature-length documentaries the
nominees are the California Reich Walter
F Parkes and Keith F Critchlow producers
fighting for our lives
Glenn piercing producer The Incredible
Machine orwen Rosten producer the man
who skied down Everest
fr Crawley James Hager and Dale Hartley
been producers the other half of the sky
a China memoir Shirley MacLaine producer
and the winner is the man who skied down
Everest fr Crowley James
Thank You sighs with milimeters coming
please be all right
here you are thank you congratulations
all of you come on crowd right in this
is an American award for a Canadian film
but a Japanese adventurer who skied down
the nepalese mountain and the mountain
happened to be called Everest as the
highest mountain in the world and in the
words of the great late PT Barnum the
whole story is incredible but true thank
you all very much
I just want to thank my mother the man
and the mountain thank you very much I'd
like to thank Bruce Muzik who did a
wonderful job in the sound and also a
special thanks to specialty films thank
you
you